The pay is attractive. You're treated like a national civil servant, and you
can earn a large salary depending on your work. I'll probably explain the details in
training, so I
'll leave it at that. Now, let's
quickly confirm.  What
can you do
?The title of national civil servant is attractive,
but being on the front lines is
dangerous.To avoid becoming a force in the field of conflict, you have to over-estimate.You
can only do so if you can.Can I see it for you
?
Well, in your case, you can create water from ze.Your
special ability is very compatible with mine.Well,
I can manipulate water, but
normally I can't create water from ze.  I
used to bring it in a petol or
buy it from a vending machine, but if you were here, the
water problem would be solved.Now I
can use my abilities without any restrictions.I can rush into more dangerous situations.Wow,
Hoshizaki-san is perfect.  Aren't you a young holic? You're
putting the existence of this and that into your emotions and you're starting to give up on your next job.In fact,
even though you don't have to go on such adventures, the
salaries of talented people are out of the blue depending on the work you do.It has
caught the attention of dangerous people.  I feel like it